in the last video I mentioned shuttle
mechanisms as the reasons why nadh --is
that are made in glycolysis could be
valued at 1.5 or 2.5 ATP so the nadh is
made in glycolysis which are made which
happens in the cytosol they cannot cross
the mitochondrial membrane their reduced
electron potential energy needs to get
into the mitochondria so I mean that so
that they can be reoxidized by the
electron transport chain right to make
ATP so we need to get these NADH is
somehow into the mitochondria but the my
identity just the nadhs can't cross the
mitochondrial membrane so how do we get
basically their reduced potential energy
into the mitochondria well the way we do
that is via one of these two shuttle
mechanisms these two shuttle mechanisms
are the mêlée aspartate shuttle and the
glycerol phosphate shuttle in the mêlée
aspartate shuttle essentially what's
going on is that if we have in the
cytosol if we have a sparked a in the
cytosol L aspartate we can change that
into oxaloacetate into oxaloacetate
using a via transamination reaction
taking alpha ketoglutarate and turning
it into glutamate ripping the amino
group off of LLS Part A attaching it to
the alpha ketoglutarate to make go to
mate and then resulting in a
oxaloacetate that's not really all too
important to this what is important
though is that once we have oxaloacetate
in the cytosol that will be concerned in
to male eight and when we do that we're
going to take an NADH
Andry oxidize it to nad plus the reason
we do that is because now male 8 is
carrying those electrons so male eight
can take those electrons in male 8 can
actually cross the mitochondrial
membrane so it's going to carry those
electrons into the mitochondrial into
the mitochondria so it carries electrons
from the NADH inside
into the mitochondria so now once the
mêlée is inside there
it can actually be it can be oxidized
into oxaloacetate and when that's
oxidized something else has to be
reduced
another thing that's actually reduced
here is NAD+ and NADH to NAD+ to NADH so
notice what happened here we we took the
instead of you know the NADH is directly
crossing the membrane because it can't
we need to move its electrons to
something that can cross the membrane
once it crosses the membrane we re
oxidized that and then we reduced nad
plus it's already actually in the
mitochondria so we make that NADH so now
oxaloacetate can be converted by tail
aspartate via sort of the reverse
reaction here and LS partake and also
across the mitochondrial membrane back
out here and then it can this process
can happen again so basically in this
case in this case this NADH right this
NADH is still an NADH so now it can go
to the electron transport chain and be
valued at 2.5 ATP so now how about the
glycerol phosphate shuttle in the bus
rock phosphate shuttle it's a little bit
different we have we start off with
dihydroxyacetone phosphate which if you
recall is from glycolysis and we're
going to take that and we're going to
reduce it to glycerol 3-phosphate and in
doing that we're oxidizing NADH to NAD+
so now glycerol 3-phosphate right
carries as electrons carry those
electrons in okay now glycerol because
goes through all three phosphate can
cross the membrane let's go through all
three phosphate is in here now it can be
oxidized into dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and we can reduce something now odd it's
odd though that instead of taking an nad
plus and turning it into an NADH we for
whatever reason take an F ad and turn it
into an fadh2 so what happened here
basically this nadh it's now valued as
an fadh2
so there's ni d8 because as fadh2 can
now be is worth 1.5 ATP this NADH it's
reduced electron energy was transported
in here and and the the coenzyme used
was an F ID and they made it an fadh2 so
now effectively this NADH which could
have been worth 2.5 ATP is now only
worth 1.5 ATP right so this can
continually happen again that I had to
actually acetone phosphate can get leave
and then this can happen again so this
is the reason why the NADH is in
glycolysis can be worth 1.5 or 2.5 ATP
depending on which shuttle they actually
go through
so clearly the Melia aspartate shuttle
is the more efficient one right this is
more efficient more energy efficient
right this is actually found in
mammalian ah
mammalian kidneys of a million kidney
the liver and the heart so clearly it's
it's the most it's the more efficient
one okay so but yeah that's the basis
for for the reasoning behind why the
NADH is from the cytosol can be worth
1.5 or 2.5 ATP it all just depends on
which shuttle there is used to transport
their stored energy into the
mitochondria hope that was helpful
thanks for watching